if you had your children here with
you here in front of you that I would tell them for the
last time
that the not very that my heart is
broken because they are my life and
one which without them my life was
complete in the blink of an eye
all my  children so many moments from the
smallest to the largest it was so
much but there were so many things so much
that they mean to me I
can't handle so much and I know I know I don't have
to live I know I have to see it I know
I have to bury them  everyone
and I was left alone without a single gene my
husband and it is too much pain but god
god can give us resignation to
endure all this and now and live it and
pass all this
what does it mean
thank you very much
because it is
not him no
and I have words